ماذا او ما
السيدات والسادة الأعزاء
مفاوضات مع الرئيس العربي
جمهورية مصر عبد الفتاح السيسي
انتقلت إلى الأعمال البناءة
في حين أنها من المقرر أن تعطيه
مدينة المبدع الاطار مافا ودات نورا و
بمعنى يقول الحاخام الجماعي وموقع الفندق
تبادل لاطلاق النار الصورة sucky danainn عليك الرد
تبادلنا وجهات النظر حول كل شيء
مجمع روسي مصري
العلاقات البالية دائما
ودية و
طبيعة متبادلة المنفعة
rangefinder أنا تعوي اشتعلت مع آلان بواسطة
ماساي notekino الروسية
كندا أنا على طريقة له حتى dawes
dopo la armata قبل مشاركة آخر نفس
وقت التعاون الثنائي
المتقدمة
ساهم بنشاط لا سيما في
اتصالاتنا المنتظمة مع المصريين
إدارة وشخصيا السيد الكعك
على الكفير من بيانات البضائع ثم الخروج
ومن ثم desura ثم أطلق عليه الرائي
وماسيا راديو اولياتا السائل والصلب الشاب والصلب
dmna وأنا أضغط سوريا
الكفوف salatu على الطريق السريع أنا أوليا موسى البضائع
واستضافت الشبكة اليوم ملف
الحديث عن التجارة والاقتصاد
تعاون
فيلق جبل النكات انها حديث ليمفوسان
عواء من ليس كذلك وكانت يخوت الصودا تحترق فيها
خاصة من إصلاح ذلك في عام 2014
زادت التجارة الثنائية بمقدار 86
في المئة هنا م هي الزيارات الأنيقة
بعد كل شيء ، فطيرة العلاج egory علاء آل الزوج
الكرة الترباس الحرب تزن الكثير
بلجيكا
صحيح هذا العام في النصف الأول
وفرق سعر الصرف وغير موات
الملتحمة تتأثر و
لقد حدث حجم تداولنا التجاري
بعض تعديل الكشف عن الحافة
القلقاس المدرفلة إلى أسفل والباردو
مجفف شعر التفتا من الميدان في أوديسا إنها متقدمة
فقط انظر أحب اللحوم مرة واحدة أرتل
بلاه في مكتب الأخدود لالا مليار والصودا
مع كلينا اتفقنا مع الرب
الرئيس على بذل الجهود اللازمة
لتقليل تأثير العوامل الخارجية
جلب تبادل البضائع على المسار
النمو المستدام
مراوح الويندوز بالتنسيقات و c في ibm db2
أي هيا أنا ليسكوفو من الخير
جيا فورس الكتان
Lika وفي الفنادق من عشاء هذا النمط الجبلي الكلب
على الطاولة
من بين الخطوات الملموسة ل
تحفيز إضافي للاقتصاد
إمكانية إنشاء منطقة حرة
التجارة في جوهرها منطقة تجارة حرة
بين مصر والاوراسيا
الاتحاد الاقتصادي والاستخدام
العملات الوطنية في التسويات المتبادلة
ترويج الاستثمار
التعاون مع تدفق الاستثمار
المتهم تحرك uvat ألمان موس للحيتان
نوافذ على أرضية مورقة وأعمال الحديقة الملكية
جنياته و mki هم هنا نظارات أم له
قاطرة على اتصالات فندق تايجر
faraday على بكرات القمامة سوف dalit بهدوء و
عث الصودا هالة آسيا الخروج من تلك المنازل
أو أتوسل إليك أن يتركوها في بعض الأحيان
ألاحظ أنه يوجد بالفعل في مصر أكثر من
400 شركة برأس مال روسي
واعدة كبيرة
قسيمة المشاريع
ومضايقة الحيض ، سيد أداتا ، أصلي
unox xr me أو إتلاف api حبة arikara
لضرب 1 أكثر
russiano أنت هنا الكربون على الكرة هيا بنا
نتوقع أن المساهمة المستمرة في ذلك
العمل هو مساهمة أساسية في هذا الإطار إذن
ستساهم وأنشأت صندوقًا مشتركًا مع
مشاركة هياكل الاستثمار الروسية
مصر والإمارات العربية المتحدة
لقد آذيت الحقيقي en tu sei الأم نفسي
هذه الكبيرة هناك أصلي من أجل صندوق للأطفال
عرض الصدر المياه الزوج الطرق تشغيل الصواريخ
سكب ألما كونت هذه التدابير
وبطبيعة الحال نشأت الأغنية أنا مساري حر
إيفان وغير سعيد وأنا أحقق تقدمًا جيدًا
مشاريع الطاقة بين الحين والآخر البضائع على حد سواء
ساق
لدينا مرحلة هلام أثينا المهنية لدينا
تدير مصر كلاً من Rosneft و Gazprom و
بما في ذلك شركتنا الأخرى
قمامة التصوير المقطعي lukoil
آسف تاريخ الكرات ومن ثم روسيا إعطاء أمي
huawei على النمو في زيت gazprom في
حرفيا واحدة من أكبر
المشاريع الثنائية هي البناء
مصر
محطة للطاقة النووية وفقا لروسيا
تكنولوجيا popey على ما يرام لبالون روما الأول
طار بسعر efima سيدي بن أوه أوه أوه
ألما من مثل هذا الانفجار ه بن ال نا
غارة أوكيناوان لا روسيا
المتخصصون من كلا البلدين يكملون
وضع الجوانب العملية
منشآت هذه المحطة الشابة أزالت الألغام
ألم الغني يثبطها
أنا لا أراهن ووجد آدم معطى
تم تحديثه مؤخرا في مصر
تم استبدال قاع قناة السويس
اعتبارات التوسع
والتعاون الصناعي ممكن
إنشاء مناطق صناعية روسية
رفع الأجر والدرج وللحنين
أحلامي جيدة ثم الوادي
أندورا بيانكي لديهم ومحور بوما
تثير العيب وبعيدا عنهم حينها
كازينو وفيلر روسي أديل مساري ط
مجال مهم للتعاون
الزراعة بالماء عليهم
هذا العطر من سيدي
المصدرين المصريين يستخدمون بنجاح
فرصنا في السوق
بالإضافة إلى ذلك بعد الاعتماد
الإجراءات التقييدية الانتقامية التي اتخذتها روسيا في
فيما يتعلق بعقوبات الاتحاد الأوروبي التي أضعها
أذهب إلى منطقة بونا لدعم الأطفال تقريبًا
أي سجن فأنا في فيات
olya rusia نعم عرض نعم وهادئ وانتهاء
المصطلح المكعب الجديد من الشرفة الجنية للخام
تم اختيار الغزلان ليوم الروبل في الأول
نصف هذا العام الاستيراد
الغذاء الغذاء
المنتجات من مصر زادت بأكثر من
بنسبة 8 في المائة
شلال نشر biocare maines وهم أنفسهم
الفيلم الأول من خطبة الفيلم للحصول على
صفر وأنا سعيد بأثينا الضخمة ذات الشكل البيضاوي
في هذه الحديقة بدورها مصر
أكبر مستهلك
وقت الاستياء الروسي من القمح فاينا
قمامة تمامًا مثل الطاولات المتبرع بها
هي أوماها روس العام الماضي لنا
وبلغت امدادات الحبوب 4 ملايين طن
وهذا 40 بالمائة من احتياجات العرب
جمهوريات القطب ، إلخ. مقلاع سنوتيل
ماتس أولمبياد تولا لاكا أماه
أربو مليون فأر بلدة فوق نعم و
بلدي اردوينو بلجيكا لي التوت القمامة
أي
خطة لزيادة سيضع رعاية واحدة
من السم و 1 الإنترنت
وناقشوا في هذا الصدد الآفاق
مشاركة الجانب الروسي في
البناء في الأراضي المصرية
مرافق البنية التحتية للحبوب بالاسم الكامل
الانزعاج من Nachman التجزئة عليهم السيدات الكونياك
الكرة أولغا له روس وإنهاء ولأجل
ليس في حالة سكر كاميرا fi router mocap أنا
نحن نعتبر أيضًا تعاونًا واعدًا في
في مجال الطيران المدني ، هو الأساس ل
، ربيع woad أسفل finna هلام
الإيرانيين نعمل على القضية المعروضة عليهم
على المستلزمات لاحتياجات المصريين
طائرات الخطوط الجوية الوطنية
سوبر جيت جاف 100 وات موجه للملك
هم البقاء هو عالم ira super jett
سنوات الجفاف التوت زوج الشرج الحمار
تواصل روسيا تقديم نماذج
المساعدة في التحضير
موظفين مؤهلين لمصر
منك أو من روسيا ، سأقدم اشتراطات
لابد أن موسى طافي وتفصيل لهذه الحفرة
أحب توسا يو التوت ألما طبقة
كما تعلم مصر تحولت الى واحد
من أشهر وجهات العطلات في
مواطنو روسيا بينما كانت غونا روبل وبعد ذلك
مع ضجة كبيرة من الأفراد على السيارة ، هل هي أصلية
شارك moffat طبقات radisu ball في عام 2014
عام
زيارات قياسية للمنتجعات المصرية
عدد الروس حوالي 3 ملايين
رجل بعيد عن الفول السوداني على الصراف
بوابة fane عملة واسعة ومحاور و
الغابة أنا روس كبير واحد لابن الطنانة
همسة مليون فرصة وهي 35
في المائة مقارنة بعام 2013
لرواية ثم شيء مساري أنا باهظ الثمن بعض الشيء
زد بلدي يركض لمشاهدة إندرمان
لا تجعد سعيد أمالفي هنا ناتاشا بالطبع
تبادل وجهات النظر خلال المحادثات
وفقًا للبحار الدولي الحالي هنا
هذا هو برجينهولم وسوف اضغط على حلال بالضبط
mafov حول الأب nl2 almu leha أو
مأهولة بالسكان لها حصلت على
مراقب
كلا الجانبين يعتقد أن الحشد
روسي مصري
تفاعل السياسة الخارجية
يلبي المصالح الأساسية لبلداننا
أتوسل إلي أن أولغا لا نعم إنه من السم
تدليك adsense cuz rus july that fig
وام أ صالح الوطنية معاق نيكل
لدينا وجهات نظر مشتركة حول
الحاجة إلى تكثيف القتال ضد
الإرهاب الدولي ، وخاصة
ذات الصلة بالنظر إلى العدوانية
تطلعات الهياكل الراديكالية من قبل
كل ما يسمى الإسلامية
الدول لديها الأدرينالين سواء اللحوم أو 0 0
1 on aray fag rad mcafee aten
تحسب
وريو برغوث الشيطان فيدورا هو عرقنا
الشتاء من حشد البوتاسيوم نحن نستبعد من تلك التعريفة
سآخذ الجد المسحب وهي ذات مرة من أندرو
هل جنحت العلوم الخاصة بي بعيدًا عن لاميا
أكد على الأهمية الأساسية
واسع
جبهة مكافحة الإرهاب بالمشاركة
اللاعبون الدوليون الرئيسيون والبلدان
المنطقة بما في ذلك سوريا
وهناك تنتظر سنوات
في أول نقع من الأرض طبخ عيد هيرودس
كرات فندق سيدة حصلت عليه نسف
المطاط والعلامة التجارية على cotoneaster vimeo
فيلم سوريا
بالطبع تحدثنا عن الآخر
القضايا المتعلقة بالوضع في المنطقة
ضرب الجوز النمس على ومع ذلك الزوجة
كتلة للحارس رمي كابل الألدان
الانزيمات وفي الختام اريد
اشكر الرئيس
جميع الأصدقاء والزملاء المصريين
مفاوضات هادفة
سوف تساهم بلا شك
مزيد من تعميق التقليدية
الصداقة والشراكة بين
روسيا ومصر وحيدة رومانوفا لك
انها الجلد فاه الرمزية ومن موقع من
الراحة و
لكن الخام على ماء علي عليموف
غارة الزملاء في المارينا تزعج Xs و
الآس عالية
على جامية لو أكاد الرواسب من ليديا
نموذج خفيف في روسيا ألاموزا
شكرا لك الموالية بسم الله نلعب فيه
خاماتوفا من هذا العالم جوتن
الأقراط الرجعية السماوية من واحد في الاسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
السادة الأعزاء ، ليس فلاديمير بوتين
رئيس الصديق الروسي
الاتحادات
ثبت هذا الجاليك أون تا هانغوك أليدا
يدرك يولكا هجوم الذكور ، إلخ.
فالير ما بيكو أولا وقبل كل شيء أريد
شكرا لك السيد الرئيس و
للدعوة الكريمة مرة أخرى
قم بزيارة موسكو ومقابلتك
مات الواقع و windows alicorn هذا لنا
الرابع مسلوق و اجتماع في سيدهم
يجف Alenka بعيدًا عن RCM الالتفات إلى ما
يؤكد الطبيعة الخاصة للعلاقة
بين شعوبنا عند شيء
يوضح أتلانتس الأمر
اليستراتس ثلاثي الابعاد ومترجم الي ايضا
يشهد على الحرب وأنت فيها
العلاقات الاستراتيجية التقليدية
بين بلدينا
ها ها ها المترو وابنها يمارس الجنس مع كاميل لها
من السهل حقا أن تصبح أو نصيحة لك
tofaken
وقدم هذا okapi الحقيقي على العشاء
السيد الرئيس ، أنا متأكد تمامًا
ماذا سيعطي لقاءنا معكم اليوم
قوة دفع إضافية لتطوير أعمالنا
العلاقات الثنائية للأطفال لا أ
لدينا بند amatory يعتزم نموذج جديد
السيد ميرونوفا على رافعة ثم نادى
التي تطورت بسرعة كبيرة
على مدى العامين الماضيين وقد حان
مستوى جديد نوعيًا لـ solera
كل فيلم bengal iter واسع
المعدل الذي نسعى فيه
تعزيز وتوسيع شراكاتنا
شراكتنا في
لديها خزان من pichuga الأخضر
يطير شيء على الرغم من tyrus أنا مرر لمن
هل البيانات وأراد آخر بسرعة
خاصة في الضوء من المواقف اللطيفة
الدولة الروسية تحت الخاص بك
الريادة في الدعم
أوقات الإرادة والاختيار والشعب الروماني
حقائق عن العد وهنا هي على هذه الهدية
tinga sena camp 8 في ذلك الوقت
قبل أن يقف وطننا
تحديات ضخمة وغير مسبوقة حول
وهي رحلة الحذاء والخفيفة 0 ص
سعر الذباب taliv mukhtarov و ilya lyakad و
وقت المغادرة و على و oleg و اليوم
الحكم مع السيد الرئيس
ناقش بوتين الخلافات وليس في الجانب
العلاقات الثنائية بيننا
دولة و 41 جلسة la-la-kati 1 منهم
عشاء يقول تأكيد فيديو كوهين
يقف العلاقات السياسية بين
من دولنا وهذا خطير من
Melia alfa ala al by junko
أماكن البحيرة لتأخذ أودي معا
سراويل للعرض
ناقش أيضا عملية وفعالة
الخطوات الواجب اتخاذها من أجل
تعزيز تعاوننا لآنا
kotova hamatora إلا في الخبز والساتان
مشى ألينا بخار رالف من الراتب الغذاء
ماء أوليج تاز وها أنت هاري خرجت منه
ماريا كاياك الناس خلال الجمل
السيد الرئيس وأنا على الطريق
اتفقنا على عدم النفعية في
زيادة حجم التجارة
العلاقات الاقتصادية والاستثمارية
بين بلدينا كركي سافينا
جلسة للإعلانات التجارية من الفحص مغادرتهم
سنوات من الحرب بين أصدقائه
دعم قوي للتنمية والتعزيز
استراتيجية طويلة المدى
العلاقات بيننا بين مصر و
مجسم ناخودا روسي باها مترو من BMP
كمين rtr هذا الكاجون يتسلق متفرقات
بلفيوري
عليا و لقال قزم أمضى الشعر وأنا
أعرب عن لسيد الرئيس بوتين و
رضاهم عما تم تحقيقه بالفعل
التقدم في هذا الاتجاه في
تم إخراج الكأس مؤخرًا
اكتساب القوة على أحد فروع التهاب الأذن الوسطى
سمارت أعمى هي باجا كاليفورنيا
بفضل أداء الجوانب الحجمية
التزامهم بالعمل معًا
في تفعيل آليات التعاون
في هجوم معين فم يشارك أقل الأسعار
و kabira wa war أعتقد ذلك في المستقبل
في المستقبل نحن ننتظر كبيرة جدا
مشجعة واذا كان
هذا gt3 عبر الإنترنت من فندق ميليا ليوكو
mittelman تكساس على طبقات أحب الأفلام
مشى ونحن نتطلع إلى الدردشة
خطوات عملية للإنشاء
المنطقة الصناعية
المنطقة الروسية بمنطقة السويس
قناة it co قبل arta malt و tempeh
مع مارات الخاسر
عندما دلتا غاري باير غاري براوننج
حماية الاستثمارات الطموحة و
هوايات تبادل السلع بيننا
الدول في الفرقاطة هل هي قيثارة كاتاك
كندا على أرما أن نموذج رأس الخاشوري
الذهاب ملهمة اللوز
في نفس السياق مفصل ماشا ماشا
في عملنا المشترك
لقد تم قطع أشواط كبيرة في الآونة الأخيرة
موضوع الوقت هو مدينة المساري المتغطرسة
مجاله القذر هو أقوى من و
فجر أ بخصوص التقدم المحرز في التعاون في
منطقة من الاستخدام السلمي للطاقة النووية
الطاقة وإذا كان حلف الناتو مفاتيح كرة القدم
لي كابير ضوء الأوركيد والبحيرات الركل
أرشيف
نحن نتطلع إلى الاستفادة
الخبرة الروسية المتراكمة لك
حياة
في منطقة مهمة على الرغم من أن التذكرة كافية
سترة الكابتن ahav العالم له وجوه عديدة
لي في أحكامنا مفاوضاتنا
تضمنت عددًا من المجالات المهمة في عيد الحب
إجمالي للتعامل معها تعتقد أنها أسعار
السدود kabira الحلال ألفا تنفق ديما
والتي من خلالها أحسب أن لدينا
التعاون المشترك
سترتفع بشكل ملحوظ في المستقبل القريب
مرة بعد هذا مون الحانات الفرح و
fado halal ikt و na king shera
أو قزم أودي 100 البالغ من العمر 40 عامًا كان مريضًا ومصابًا
oltany bayonetta الناس هذه الأسئلة
ستتم مراجعة ومناقشة بالتفصيل.
خلال الجلسة العاشرة
اللجنة الحكومية الدولية في
التجارة الاقتصادية والاقتصادية و
التعاون العلمي والتقني بين
بلادنا للعبث بها لها
فلوريس x إيطالي طويل
اجتماع أولغا الذي سيعقد في
الاجتماع الذي سيعقد في مصر من قبل
نهاية العام الحالي للمعلق كما
كرنك موناكو أو تأثير فيلم المختارة
هل أوليغ رأيتهم ، هل أخذتها
نفركها ، وسيكون الزوج أيضًا في المفاوضات
الدولية و
ريغا ودوي الإقليمية التي
توفر لي ولي مصلحة الخروج
ثني الثرى
توت العليق نغمات الزبدة الداخلية
لياهو نسر ريل احتياطي الطاقة وأنا
إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن ندرك في سقوطنا
المصالح وإدخال حل لها
أسئلة حول القتال مع معرفة جنية الكمين
فوضى الوتد أوليا تمنحها كما هي
نسخة أشرق تعطيل نخر المدرسة
على وجه الخصوص ، أكدنا الحاجة
أسمح سلمي بأيدي سياسية
تسوية الأزمة السورية في
وفقا لأحكام جنيف
بلاغ uac 1
العلامة تصنيف وجوه الورقية وهكذا
مثل ثعالب كلارك وقبعة أوسات
أواني التاكسي المائي كرات من الخشب الصلب
أوليا ومدى حجمنا أيضًا
أكد على أهمية القرار
المشكلة الفلسطينية
بما في ذلك منح الأوقات للفلسطيني
الناس من حقوقهم القانونية
ميداليات سيئة tyrus لذلك بالنسبة لك المحرك
بما في ذلك إنشاء الذوق الخاص بك
دولة مستقلة عاصمتها في
شرق القدس كندا كم
كندا الحشو ذريعة lah ركوب إلى
غضب أوليسيا فيليبر
ولكن أيضًا ناقش الوضع الزمني في
توقيت العراق والأحداث الأخيرة في
تذاكر ليبيا ورخيصة الثمن لمقدم الطلب الغني
تدقيق هومر الأمومة بما في ذلك الأساليب
مواجهة
مفاجأة الإرهاب التي تهدد
التي تهددنا جميعًا ، كل شيء يطير
روبرت بالنسبة لكما جمعت حقائق لا تقدر بثمن
فيلم rosenbaum tuatara mth ألف لاسو
ausat لدينا حتى تفاهم مشترك
فيما يتعلق بحقيقة أن هذه الظاهرة
المرتبطة بنقاط التوتر الساخنة
الشرق الأوسط
ضرب من غريب نحيل أسرار الفيلم الخاصة على
ما يملي علينا تطوير و
تكثيف التعاون و
المشاورات بيننا
ركلات stilt gizia elizabeth movie nth
أسافين الطعام حملتك وأنت محب
رودريغو أنا أنت تسحبني في فتات الخبز
2ـ حل البحث الجذري لهذه المشاكل متى
ضمانات النزاهة والوحدة و
السلامة الإقليمية و
أمن دول المنطقة
خاميتوفا لديها بوكين ، ولكن في المنزل مرة أخرى
غزال الفرس
أتحدث باسم فريق البايك للحظة فقط
مخدع المشروبات الكحولية البوريس لدي
اليسار هو طبقات كندا أولغا رينا
بالفعل على السيد الرئيس بوتين أريد
الاستفادة من هذه الفرصة
وأعبر عن خالص شكري
للأعلى تخيلوا وجود روسيا
لافتتاح قناة السويس العلمانية الجديدة
قناة ملكة جمال سيلين البطل لو ش زورو و
روس
يا فاليجو حتى ابن طاغية نسخة آلان
مرهف يجرؤ على الموقد في وجه السيد
رئيس جهاز الحكومة
الاتحاد الروسي كان مرتفعًا
مصنفة في مصر على المستوى الرسمي و
قوم مستوى 8 صد حمد الطيران
ماراثون مغرة حظيرة النبيذ لا يزال الأسطول
يعطي pdair olya و gai نائب الرئيس على القارئ
الروسية
حلبة التزلج على الجليد أوليا الكهف التي تركتها هي لاسو و
دعني أعبر لك سيدي
امتنان الرئيس الصادق و
الامتنان على هبة الحرب
المعدات البحرية الروسية التي
شارك في حفل الافتتاح
قناة السويس بشارع الرعاة على الفراء
أوميغا 3 ولكن أخيرًا عندما كانت صغيرة ليليانا
بالقرب من الأم ثم انزعاج lacad alva
كان الألم لا يزال على حد سواء وشعب العالم على ذلك
الإيماءات العميقة التي كانت
التي اتخذها المصريون كدليل
6 ـ الصمود خير
علاقات الصداقة بين شعوبنا و
الدول
raspberry futari anglo revolta إما
نموذج عامل الخندق الحلال
الجنية مجبرة بالأحرى نعم ، ولنا معها
روسيا له وأود أيضا أن أعبر عن بلدي
سوف يصل لهم الرضا
التقدم والنجاح في التنمية
وتقوية علاقاتنا في الجيش
أضاء السراف التعاون إذا أوتا
عشاء دربت و اخي بدر الشقيقة
الوقت له قمة
alleri في تدريب التسلح
تبادل الخبرات الشخصية
وكذلك في مجال المساعدة في المكافحة
الإرهاب
قناة من شريط الروك خارج المشهد على الإنترنت
فرقة المدينة هنا من أنت وأنا
نتطلع إلى استمرار مكثفة
العمل في هذا المجال و
تفعيل الآليات
الإيمان المشترك يجادل نفسك من القمامة
الحبال والكوليرا
نفد أكثر من 100 كرور له في القبعة
صورة 1 من 7
ضمن مصلحتنا المشتركة
في تحقيق الاستقرار في القريب
الشرقية وضمان الدولية
الأمان
وعلى الأقل على العمود الفقري أو العضد المريح
من غاليش سيقود نيسان
ما هي أوراق تلميع أوبل هلام الكبش وفي
استكمال أود أن أعبر لكم مرة أخرى
السيد الرئيس و الشكر و
الشعب الروسي الصديق
الامتنان على الترحيب الحار و
صواني الضيافة بالنسبة لنا sori a
مثل بارونيت الفروع من الفندق اضح علاء
غزل الثعبان هو استراتيجية مختل عقليا
معبأة وأريد أن أشير إلى أن مصر
وقد أكدت روسيا مؤخرا
نواياها لتعزيز الاستراتيجية
العلاقات بين بلدينا التل أ
ثم بوند هارفي وولفيكا
هنا أمر أوراكل لإرساله من قبل المعجبين
المكسرات وأنا هناك
لنفتح الاسادة بطرق بولاك تور
على أساس السياسية و
ربما التقارب الفكري
التراث التاريخي يقوم على بلدي
الصداقة والاحترام المتبادل بيننا
بلدان وشعوب أمور ليازينا من ق
تشغيل و
جانك إلى سيراف جيجابت مع هذا بالذات
نعتز بإجمالي مترو فاجا إستيرو
الصغار لديهم الخشخاش ليسوا عمق هذه الأولي
leroy pelvis أو إطلاقات الحسناء المغمورة
في جميع الأسواق التي تطير حول رز ياروشا أنا شخصيًا
أعول على السيد الرئيس في نهاية المطاف
كان التفاعل معك يقوي و
تطوير استراتيجيتنا
شراكات علاقات استراتيجية في
شكرا لاهتمامكم في المستقبل
السيد الرئيس